Alemania ha soltado sus laupers ahora
todas las miras están puestas en Francia
luego de que el cancillero laugh schols
aceptara la entrega de tanques leopard 2
a Ucrania Se informa que Estados Unidos
está listo para enviar 30 de sus M1
abrams y el Reino Unido proporciona 14
challengers 2 la presión se traslada al
presidente Emmanuel macrón para que
envíe el principal tanque de batalla de
Francia el leclerc
le he pedido al ministro de defensa que
trabaje en este tema no se descarta nada
no Debería ser una escalada y siempre
hemos adoptado este enfoque en segundo
lugar esto debería proporcionar un apoyo
real y efectivo a nuestros amigos
ucranianos
entre las reservas el gobierno está el
hecho de que muchos leclercs no están en
funcionamiento alrededor de la mitad de
su existencia de 400 no está operativo y
otros 50 están siendo actualizados las
fuerzas francesas querrán retener la
mayoría para la defensa del país por lo
que es probable que entreguen apenas una
pequeña cantidad para
ex oficial al mando de un escuadrón de
leclerc esto aún requeriría recursos
logísticos significativos por lo que no
sería una buena inversión para el
esfuerzo de guerra sería imposible
entregar más de lo que vale un escuadrón
de equipo alrededor de 14 tanques esto
no haría una diferencia en el gran
esquema de operaciones y no sería una
disposición efectiva para el ejército
ucraniano al gobierno francés también le
gustaría que los tanques se usaran
únicamente como medios defensivos para
no aumentar las tensiones con Rusia ante
lo cual Ucrania bien Podría argumentar
que cualquier operación para evitar la
invasión de Rusia contaría como
defensiva